the time is coming when the human race
will get to the moon with rockets
private companies won't want to do this
are they gonna make money by charging
for the ride
those crazy billionaires competing with
each other modern-day rocket man wants
to send you to Mars difficult dangerous
good chance you'll die the private
industry space race is on
we tend to think that space exploration
and human spaceflight is all about
governmental agencies like NASA but it
wasn't really always like that some of
the very first steps by the early
rocketry pioneers were funded by the
private sector in the u.s. it begins
with the University of Clarke professor
Robert Goddard it's 1920 and he
publishes a method of reaching extreme
altitudes mentioning that rockets could
be used to carry payloads to the moon
editorial writer imply that your husband
didn't even know high school physics in
1926 Goddard successfully launches the
first liquid-fueled rocket money from
the family of the mining magnate daniel
guggenheim soon follows they provided
him funding in today's dollars at scale
of tens of millions of dollars what's
interesting is that at the very start of
this period in the 1920s there was
actually a great amount of enthusiasm
and a great amount of belief in the
potential for these private rockets to
go to space the German war machine gets
underway the second world war gets
Rockets a home you need and then the
knowledge of rocketry became critical to
a cold war and in the 50s and 60s
rocketry was almost exclusively a
governmental affair the private sector
in terms of companies was essentially
working as contractors to the US
government it's not until 1982 that a
serious effort is made to build a
privately funded rocket the idea comes
from a Texas businessman David Hanna jr.
conestoga one is pieced together from a
repurposed ballistic missile
it may not have had the majesty of an
Apollo or the Thunder of a shuttle but
it flew and that's what caught
everything speeds up at the turn of the
millennium when freshly minted
millionaires take interest one of them
is Jeff Bezos I don't actually hold out
great hopes but if I could do anything I
would like to go help explore space a
few months later he sets up Blue Origin
then
Elon Musk starts SpaceX and yet another
tech millionaire
Anousheh Ansari and her family promised
to foot the bill for XPrize this is a 10
million dollar award for reaching the
industry's holy grail a reusable manned
space vehicle in 2004 spaceship 1 wins
the prize Richard Branson buys the
rights turns it into Virgin Galactic and
in the same year starts accepting
commercial reservations for future
suborbital flights although we are
seeing a lot of billionaires have
interest in spaceflight their
investments still pale in comparison to
governmental investments and they have
now managed to partner in many cases
with US government agencies and NASA for
example is in most years SpaceX's
primary customer but there are setbacks
local companies mission for NASA
explodes into a ball of fire and debris
deadly crash involving Virgin Galactic's
spaceship to a SpaceX rocket bringing
supplies to the International Space
Station as you can see there it exploded
eventually in 2015 blue origins new
shepard rocket becomes the first to take
off and land vertically after reaching
space
shortly after SpaceX goes even further
sending its Falcon 9 to orbit altitude
the other major milestone will be the
first tourists on commercial suborbital
vehicles and I'm not gonna predict who
who's gonna be there first but the hope
is that by having more competition
amongst commercial companies and by
leveraging advanced technologies that
we're gonna be able to reduce the cost
of going into space 2019 is the year
that SpaceX and Boeing are gearing up to
finally take astronauts up to the
International Space Station the first
private lunar lander is on its way to
the moon and Chinese companies are
joining the space race as well people
have been dreaming and thinking and
planning for a future for Humanity
beyond this planet and that includes a
future for Humanity on the surface of
the Moon future for Humanity on Mars and
even farther still and as long as we
have a social goal of continuing to
expand our knowledge of the cosmos then
the ambitions and dreams of individuals
are going to be an important part of
realizing those goals
[Music]
you
you